what's up everyone we're back on the V
Jane we are now I'm gonna be talking
about the importance of incentivizing
innovation you and your wife just funded
the 1 million dollar women's safety
XPrize and you guys had a really
incredible invention come out of it Leif
yes and so this sort of idea talked
about that idea of incentivizing
innovation the importance of women's
safety so first of all we achieve the
behavior we incentivize so if you
incentivize something that's a behavior
we expect people to do and the good
thing about XPrize and the good thing
about incentive prizes is it acts like a
massive magnet that allows the people
from all over the world to come look at
the problem you want solve yeah
right and the beauty of the prizes is
you only pay when the problem is solved
according to how you define that problem
needs to be solved yeah right that means
instead of you looking for needle in the
haystack the needle comes to you and say
hey look at me yeah right now what we
did in the women's safety prize was we
say it is not a third world problem this
is a problem that happens in our country
in every college campus I mean this is
not a girl who will tell you that they
didn't feel uncomfortable at some point
of time in their life here right we
decided that you know instead of talking
about it instead of bitching about it we
said let's go put our money where our
mouth is what if we can incentivize
people with a million dollar cash prize
and we won't ask for nothing in return
no equity no nothing we simply give it
to them if they were to come up with a
device that would cost less than $40 and
that can be so easy to use and so hidden
that no one knows where it is and would
not require the cellphone because people
attacker takes a cell phone away yeah
what if this device could work on its
own without the cell network that mean
you could be on a basement of a building
when there's no cell signal it is still
will work yes and on top of that what if
your hands are tied what if you're you
know tape them out
how would you come
and to that this what came out of this
was amazing the biosensors that could be
put anywhere on the body it will it will
monitor the how you are breathing it
will monitor you pray turn you could
design it to cuff in a certain way the
breathe in a certain way that will say I
am in danger it automatically uses the
mash network to send the signal to your
loved ones to the cops and say this is
the location and this is what's going on
and by the way it starts to do the audio
and video recording so it's no longer
about Hesiod she said it is she said and
she has a proof yes right it's recording
everything that's going on in fact you
could hear it on the other end what's
going on yeah so okay so tell us about
the winners the device this was
obviously so we you know when we
announced surprise hundred-and-some team
competed for it in 40 different
countries and the final thing about all
the diversity of creativity that comes
from around the world the song here's
the best part in every incentive prizes
that we saw who was that the people who
end up actually being the finalists and
the people who actually win the prize
never come from the industry it always
the people who are non expert looking in
people who are outside the industry and
the only reason they're solving the
problem is they care about solving the
problem plus the price and that's the
beauty the things to the people that
came out were out of Sweden out of China
out of university students I mean really
in the team from India an idea was that
these people came together with very
many different solutions all different
sensor technologies all different ways
the problem can be solved and the fact
is it doesn't matter who won because
everyone who competed is going to go out
and win in the marketplace and the only
winner is us as humanity it's not the
team that won there were the conduit the
ultimate ultimate winner is not even the
women it is the society because they
allowed the women to be at their best
because they are the one who are going
to move the
80 followers and that's the reason I
believe it is not a prize didn't just go
to the team it just didn't go to the
women safety it really goes to the
benefit of society yeah that's great
okay and then what is what are we
wearing what is the win so again all the
different teams have different ideas
Europe some of them are a small patch
that could be put anywhere in the body
some are rings some are pendants some
are ear rings some are it could be or
some are tiny sensors you could put
anywhere you want so you could take that
and say put that in the earring one day
put in the pendant next day put in the
you know ring one day you want and it
could be anybody you want it could be
new watch if you want and it works with
with GPS but and it also works without
cellular service Wow yeah this is and
how do you know how to put the
technology is that enables it to work in
the mesh network mesh and yeah mesh
network em yes and yes it basically
jumps from device to device to device it
doesn't require the cell signal so it's
literally jump from device to device to
device huh so it finds nearby devices
that are connected to networks and then
it says emergency signals through the
emergency okay all right what is next in
incentivizing prices do you guys have an
idea yeah so we're actually working on
as you know that I'm on the board of
XPrize and we have multiple XPrize is
currently in place Elon Musk is funding
a prize for literacy and the idea is can
we take someone who has never seen a
technology does not read right or does
any math in 18 months from beginning to
end can be fluent in reading writing and
math Wow and that think right that is a
15 million dollar prize there's going to
be an ad that's hopefully will be won in
the next 12 to 18 months it's already
being tested we have prizes for ocean
cleaning we have prizes for right now
for Alzheimer diseases we have prizes
for remote robots that essentially you
can control from your human body sitting
here a robot that somewhere else that
essentially becomes your surrogate of
doing things right so you could
literally be sensing and feeling through
that robot and the robot it really
becomes your eyes and ears in
some other location yeah I love
incentivizing innovation I think it's a
very smart way like you said to bring
the needle to you rather the day you
threw the haystack for the needle and
there's so much brilliance and
creativity from around the world that
can really go into solving these hugely
challenging problems awesome that's
that's a great piece on XPrize a huge
thank you again for funding that woman's
thank you the XPrize that's really thank
you